Chính phủ đưa đợi thông qua sự lợt cho phát cảnh sát được quyền bắn hạc,
Phóc vô hiệu hóa tí bị bài không người lãi sâm phạm khương phận trong cái tình vòn gây nguy hiểm nghiêm trọc.
Đồng thấy này chỉ giải sò hàng loạt vụ thí bị bài không người lãi, trái phép,
làm giám đoạn hẳn đậm của nhiều sinh bay lở nở cho ông,
chúng đoạn của sự có tệ sinh bay mùn íc, khiến hơn người nghi ngành khách bị mắc kẹp.
Theo sự lợt, cảnh sát của thế giữ giống các biển pháp kỹ thuật, nhiều tính hiệu người dễ ổ,
tìa là sẽ phóc bắn hạc chữ tiết để các liên kết điều kiện của thế bị.
Tuy nhiên, quy định này vẫn phải được có hội đất thông qua trước khi có hiệu lực.
Gió loại tất cả ông liên ăn thật sự sự ở khu bựng đô thị đông dân cơ,
với chính xinh mới, đếp trở thành một trong số íc của sát cho ông,
cùng ăn pháp, lýt và vào lôn mân nhà chính thức chào chơi lực lượng ăn nền,
quyền mắn hạ thì bị bài không người lãi, nhà bảo đam ăn toàn của xa và chữ tự công cậm.